the isfaro river looking south towards
the pamere ally mountains
the road winds through a mountain
landscape that kyrgyzstan and tajikistan
have repeatedly fought over
because borders here are indistinct
the burnt out military and civilian
vehicles are evidence of the most recent
fighting
what started as an argument between
kyrgyz and tajik villagers about control
of a water pump
escalated into a battle between two
armies
houses and schools were destroyed at
least 50 people were killed and tens of
thousands fled their homes
i was in the house when i heard shooting
in the village when the tajik soldiers
came
i left close by 20 kilometers inside
kyrgyzstan is a part of tajikistan
this is the border post for the tajik
territory of varuk
it is home to around 30 000 tajiks
and the area is completely surrounded by
kyrgyz territory
and it has become the flash point for a
border dispute that has its roots
in the soviet past
is one of two tajik exclaves inside
kyrgyzstan
borders are complicated because soviet
map makers drew lines between republics
of the ussr
and when the soviet union collapsed they
became the blueprint for boundaries of
independent states through which
waterways and farmland crossed
thirty years later only around half the
thousand kilometer frontier
between kyrgyzstan and tajikistan is
demarcated
as local populations have grown so has
the competition for land and water
villagers are worried fighting could
start again
my family were evacuated i don't know
whether to bring them back
it seems like our neighbours consider us
the enemy we face
unexpected attacks a nearby village is
almost deserted
with each side blaming the other for the
violence
one side of the village is the other is
tajik the shooting started in the middle
of the night
started it by throwing stones at our
soldiers i tried to flee but it was too
dangerous
analysts say it will take more than
political will
to resolve the issue the situation is
very dangerous and we
saw what sort of an intensity
the conflict can take at the end
at the end of april it takes a lot of
very principled and very clever
diplomatic
work by both governments to prevent
another escalation reminders of how
lethal this border dispute can be
litter the mountainside communities
more distrustful and divided than before
chance stratfor al jazeera aksai
southern kyrgyzstan